hey i'm christian i'm an outdoor
adventure photographer living full-time
on the road in my converted van
it's been three and a half years since i
last had a real address and besides my
old suv this tiny home on wheels has
been the only place i've called home
since
last month i left behind the van for the
first time and traveled to europe with
five really good friends this is the
first part of our story
from seattle to the swiss alps
[Music]
that's
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's another day in the huddle household
[Music]
today we go to europe um we're leaving
in like four hours and i'm still in the
process of packing actually just started
this morning
and i've got stuff everywhere
i have stuff
inside matt renee's house too which
really really fortunate that they're
letting us pack here and shower here and
do all those things because there's so
much to do ahead of an international
trip
and there's a couple extra steps i'm
taking just because this is the longest
i will be leaving the van ever
yeah i've never left the band this long
before so
um a couple extra steps that i'm taking
like i put the plants
inside the house so that they don't get
too cold out here and i emptied out and
cleaned the fridge i'm gonna be turning
off all the power when i leave including
the ac and dc currents i don't think my
fridge has ever looked so clean unless
you count the day that i got it oh and i
put a little desiccant in there i don't
know if that's a good idea but
just to keep moisture out and hopefully
no bacteria
will form in there here's just a quick
flyby of what i've got packed so far or
set out i should say i'm undecided how
many fleeces i'm gonna take or shirts
but this is
kind of a preliminary pile of stuff and
i'm gonna see what will fit in that bag
that's the only checked bag i'm taking
and then i'm taking my peak design
everyday pack for all of my camera gear
for this trip i'm taking the canon r5
the 24 to 72.8 15 and 35 2.8 and the 100
to 500 taking a bunch of extra batteries
um filter
and microphone odds and ends here's my
peak design tripod here's a top down
view of my bag i've got the 100 500 here
uh beanie for cushion i got all my
lithium batteries back there and here i
got one of my lenses um in the middle
another lens and on the other side i've
got my r5 so up here we'll go everything
that needs to be easily accessible on
the plane including um some tech gear in
my tech pouch and my laptop will go
right back here
and here is my drone which these have to
go into my carry-on but i'll probably
end up packing
the drone itself in my luggage here are
my toiletries for the trip i've got
shampoo conditioner this is going to go
with me in my
carry-on and then makeup and then just
various odds and ends all right i'm all
packed up i've got all my camera gear my
laptop everything that i need for the
plane is right there
all my really important stuff um this
tech pouch fits right up here in the top
and then i have my one suitcase i have
my drone my tripod my toiletries all my
clothes my shoes everything fits in
there just fine and
yep that's everything i'm gonna have for
the next
three weeks
and
kova test we made it into the car we got
all the bags we got all the people
everybody's here
i had a lot of mixed emotions going into
this trip for a few different reasons
one this was my first time leaving the
van for so long
i'm so used to having everything i own
with me at all times the thought of
parking my whole life in a driveway and
leaving it there unattended felt a
little strange doors closing please
stand clear
two i used to live in italy and this was
my first time back since 2013. i was a
little nervous to see how much italian i
would remember and just how it would
feel being back
three like i've mentioned before i'm an
extroverted introvert which means i need
a lot of alone time to recharge
and i was nervous about traveling and
living with five other people for three
weeks straight
all right our plane is delayed
it sure is
we've been on the runway for how long
two hours two hours
we're gonna make it fourth this was my
first time traveling overseas since
before the pandemic
what i can say is traveling during covid
comes with a lot of uncertainty all six
of us are fully vaccinated which made
things a little easier but that was only
one piece of the puzzle
all right where's the first stop now
that we're in london
coffee shop toilet
we're going to zurich we're going to
zurich zurich finally
getting into switzerland via england
required filling out quite a few forms
downloading an app and uploading all our
information and then downloading another
app in switzerland and applying for
clearance so that we could be allowed
into restaurants
it was a process and the most
nerve-wracking part was leaving europe
when we were required to pass a kova
test before boarding the plane and found
out last minute that the tests we packed
in our suitcases weren't going to cut it
but yeah more about that in the next
video anyway despite all that i was
really excited to be back in europe and
after a long day of travel we picked up
our friend ally from zurich and drove
straight into the mountains
checking into our first hotel here in
switzerland
thank you
oh perfect
i'm so excited to sleep we've been
traveling for a long time
we had an overnight flight from seattle
and i stayed up all night the night
before that editing
and
finally made it through we went to
london now we're in switzerland we got
the cars went to customs we did all the
things we found parking and now we are
finally in
the hotel room
[Music]
i like that
i like that
[Music]
all right grocery shopping
getting all the veggies
so many good breads
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
in switzerland
[Music]
here's our first hotel in switzerland
here is home for the next three days
in zyno
here we've got a strange man living in
here
this is so nice
nice wood detail
and so we got three different rooms
we got this nice cow chair
very aesthetic fitting for switzerland
ah hello from switzerland
it's so pretty here so we have this
trail right behind our hotel
we're going up
that looks pretty interesting already
[Music]
so it's just after sunrise and we're
going to hike
up
there
to get a better view of the peaks out
there
we saw a handful of van lifers camped
out on pull-offs on our way out to this
place it definitely made me wish i had
my own van over here switzerland
especially felt a lot safer than some of
the places i tend to base in the us
a local here shared that it's pretty
safe to leave your things visible inside
a vehicle to leave your car unlocked i
don't know if that's true or not but
theft is something i constantly think
about in the states leaving my van at a
trailhead just isn't an option unless
i'm willing to risk a break-in and also
as far as i know switzerland and italy
don't have dangerous wild animals like
we do back home
oftentimes hiking on a trail alone after
dark or before sunrise means risking a
run-in with a mountain lion rare but
always a possibility
anyway this was just one of the first
places we explored that got me thinking
about shipping the van over here myself
someday
[Music]
[Music]
just hiked up from the hotel
which is
down in that valley
and hiking for about an hour hour and a
half
and it's just so beautiful up here
it's midday so the lights not that crazy
but
wow
these mountain peaks are something else
found this really cool rock to sit on
up here at the top
surrounded by mountains and i'm up at
this mountain hut there's no one up here
it's
so peaceful
and my friends all went on a different
hike and
i guess i just i really needed a day to
myself with all the traveling and i've
been doing a lot of social activities
lately and
yeah it just kind of takes it out of me
sometimes no matter how much i love the
people i just need time to myself so
that's what i'm doing right now and i
can't think of a better place to do it
this is so nice
we are going on a hike and we're not
entirely sure where the trail is
but we're trying to figure it out as we
go
so we have to cross a river of solid ice
then we have to go up this trail
and around this very
skinny cliff
oh
and it's uh it doesn't look good
all right we're gonna go back she's
sketchy we're going back we went the
wrong way
very tired
how are you feeling yeah
i'm so tired it's not running out of my
nerves right now all right so this hike
is turning out to be a mega slog
how
how far have we gone matthew
we've gone
only about 1.5 miles but this trail was
meant to be two miles 2000 feet of
elevation gain but what we didn't
realize is that 1.4 miles is flat
yeah
so now we're just going straight uphill
we're at pretty high elevation pretty
high altitude already and yeah and the
vultures have started to circle us
yeah we can hear them
they're up there they're not gonna make
it
that's fine i really do think
switzerland might be the most insane
country it's so beautiful
[Music]
so
[Music]
we finally
made it up
a really steep climb
and these views
are so worth it
you can tell i can barely breathe
i'm so tired
but we're almost there how are we
feeling renee
so tired
we made it to the top
this was seriously the hike that never
ended
is so beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
a lot of people think travel is a form
of distraction it's a way of running
away from life
i disagree for me travel has always been
a mirror it offers up perspective and
forces me to take a good hard look at
myself and the life i'm living
[Music]
everybody happy
happy i could cry i could cry i'm so
happy right now i could cry
it does look really good
all packed up
heading to our next spot
two cars that were loading up
and we're heading out to engadine
really gonna miss this place
travel highlights all the things i
missed back home and also all the things
i'd like to change it amplifies emotion
in my case emotion about going back to a
country i once called home about
traveling in a group as an introvert
about leaving the van and potentially
risking quarantine in a foreign country
it's easy to pretend that none of that
was going on behind the scenes but it
was like so many things in this weird
life of mine it was a true adventure
beautiful challenging and just getting
started
i will see you guys next week when we
head to italy
just get in the shot in switzerland
nice
is it still smoking
it smells like crap
[Music]
[Music]
you